today I want to show you how I built the
living roof for the mini shed that holds
our power system inside are the
batteries inverter and control for our
solar system from renergy I started by
measuring how big the piece of ply needs
to be I cut the pressure treated plywood
a little big and stiffened it up with 1
by 6 Cedar then I trimmed all four sides
with 1 by 4 seater you can see the roof
will have a slight pitch I attached two
by four so the roof has something to
slide back and forth on then I place the
roof on top and started laying a rubber
barrier for more protection I flipped
the roof over and added an extra piece
to each Edge so that it would slide up
on the rails more easily I covered the
roof with sandy loam and then added a
rock retaining wall so I could make the
soil deeper then I started placing all
the cactuses yes it's heavy but I can
move it back and forth when I need to
and because the renergie batteries are
Bluetooth I can check their status
without even having to this air gap
that's created by the rails allows the
system to breathe and not overheat
that's it next time I'll take you on a
tour inside the cabin and show you all
the things this renergie solar system
powers